poor friends came about Lorne Michaels
wanted you to be a part of the Saturday
Night Live cast oh I didn't think I
would like that environment and I
remember showing up and Sandler was
there and spade was there and I've known
them or I had known them already it's
like no the Aniston's here he went for
an audition I was such a young quit I
was like I think the women need to be
treated better here and I don't like
boys club yeah I you know you're so
you're just not the brightest when you
early twenties
Jennifer ended up having the best of
both worlds TV icon with friends and
occasional SNL host with classic skits
she appeared with Howard Stern at Sirius
XM's new Hollywood studio off-camera the
single star completely shut down an
offer to set her up do you want me to
set you up with somebody when I listen I
just don't like being set up I don't
like it Jennifer's out promoting her new
Apple TV Plus series with Reese
Witherspoon
the morning show we are doing this my
way as for friends well a few months ago
she gave us hope a reboot could happen
know was getting me nowhere so I thought
I'd try us see what happens now not so
much if there is a reboot of the show it
won't be even close to as good as what
as what it was so Wyatt why do I would
ruin it it would ruin it
[Music]
[Applause]